Erin, hey!
Beth, lovely to see you, my dear.
Always lovely to see you.
I'm excited about today's episode.
What have you got on deck for us?
I have a question that we get asked a lot that hopefully I'm going to show some ways
to sort of figure out how to answer, which is quantifying your staining, especially quantifying
if your staining is punctate, like how many puncta do you have, things like that.
So I've got a little sub-parfile pipeline, I've got a little sort of data exploration
demo.
Nice.
Though, you know, clarifying question, when we're talking about puncta, do you mean sparkles,
can we call them sparkles?
We can absolutely call them sparkles.
How sparkly are our cells?
Love it.
Yes.
Asking the real important questions.
So, to quantify how sparkly our cells are, I grabbed some data from the Brode Bio-Image
Benchmark Collection, where we have some U2OS cells that have a reporter that has GFP
and it has from very small amounts of drug to huge amounts of drug, and the more drug,
the more sparkly.
Love it.
Yeah.
So, I threw together a quick CellProfiler pipeline.
There's a couple extra steps that you wouldn't necessarily always need.
Specifically, there's a couple of smoothing steps here, because this is pretty old data
and it's JPEG.
Oh my goodness.
So, just to get rid of some of those compression artifacts and things like that, if you're
saving data, please don't use JPEGs.
JPEGs make your data sad.
I think we even have a podcast episode about, like, why does my data look bad?
We do.
That's true.
We call out JPEGs.
So, we can link that in the show notes.
Yes.
So, here's some not-so-pretty-looking data.
And here it is sort of a little bit smoothed out.
So, these two smoothing steps are not things you would normally need to do.
I've got an identify primary objects module.
So, I wanted to sort of give us a few different ways to look at this.
So, we'll count the number of spots, but we're also going to just look at, like, nuclei
cells inside of plasm.
So, I have my nuclei.
I then use identify secondary objects to turn those nuclei into cells.
Nice.
Yeah.
Looks like cells.
We have some tertiary objects to make cytoplasms.
And then, as we've talked about before in terms of finding sparkles, the enhancer-suppressed
features module can be really nice for that.
And so, let me zoom in and adjust my contrast just to make it nice and bright.
You can see that lets us get rid of all of this background signal and leave only the
puncta that are left.
I then chose to mask the puncta to only what's inside the cytoplasm.
And that's because we get this nuclear rim effect around the nuclei, which isn't really
the thing we want to measure.
So, I eventually want to be able to get rid of that.
And so, masking with the cytoplasms will help in a way that I'll show you right now.
So, when I do my puncta identification, I do a couple of things.
The first thing is you might notice a bunch of orange here in the bottom left.
Orange is for things being thrown out that are touching the edge.
These are all the things that are touching the edge of my nucleus and things that I don't
necessarily want because I'm mostly just getting the nuclear rims here.
And so, by doing that masking, I mean it allows me to turn that setting on and just get rid
of the nuclear rim like one shot easy peasy.
That is such a creative trick and a way to take advantage of.
So, I mean, even recently, I forgot about this setting.
So, I know in CP5, we're changing our language on our module a tiny bit just to make this
even more clear.
But in the module settings, filtering objects that touch edges, most of the time you think
of the edge of an image, which makes sense of, oh, I don't want to make measurements
about this object if most of it is cut, if part of it is cut off in my image.
That makes total sense.
But sort of forget that that also includes masks.
And so, you can get tricked by, I mean, here, we're using that trick to our advantage, a
perfect thing here where actually, yeah, brilliant use of that.
I had not thought of taking this thing that sometimes currently trips me up even despite
many years of expertise and using it to do exactly what we want in a relevant manner.
Yeah, I mean, there's a reason every setting is in CellProfiler and sometimes it's a
bad reason and sometimes it's a good reason, but we can always sort of try to use our powers
for good.
I then added a bunch of measurement modules.
We've got size and shape of both the cells in the punta.
We've got the intensity of the cells in the punta in that GFP channel.
And then I added some other.
I noticed a thing here, Beth, that I want to call out.
So usually when we do things that are pipe out, I mean, people, if you've watched more
than one episode, I'm sure you've heard us say more than once, you know, all is fair
in love and war and image analysis for object identification.
But when you're making measurements, they always need to be on the input image.
But what I notice here is that you're not acting.
Yeah, I broke the rules.
You broke a rule.
I'm bad.
But I think that's a really important thing to call out.
While this may be an absolute must rule, almost every single time.
You know, here there's an exception for that very reason that you called out in the beginning.
This is you're actually getting rid of an artifact by using this smooth, not just doing
tricks to find objects.
Yeah.
When we do our bootcamp, I usually caveat that rule with unless you're doing a measured
correction or things like that.
Like if you're doing something that you know is a correction and you can specify exactly
why it is and what it is and it's calibrated, then you might not need to be working on the
raw image.
And that's, you know, how we often measure on illumination corrected images.
But here there is an artifact coming from the JPEG compression.
And so the most sort of pure representation of the image I can get is this one that actually
has a tiny bit of something like that.
Yeah.
So that's good to point out.
I also added some texture and granularity measurements in that same smooth JFP channel
just so that we can sort of take a look at, you know, what those are.
So texture is going to sort of tell us, you know, at different spacings throughout the
data.
Essentially, you know, here I have a spacing of three, like in any given pixel, like how
similar is the intensity in the pixel three pixels away from it in every direction.
Granularity is a little bit harder to explain.
But thankfully, someone has made a lovely diagram helping explain it.
With granularity, what we're doing is we're actually iteratively removing sort of dots
of various sizes.
And so we're seeing how much of our signal is in very small spots versus slightly small
spots versus, you know, even bigger spots versus even bigger, bigger spots.
And so it gives us a level of punctaiteness.
It's a little harder to interpret because these steps are done iteratively.
And so if we say that our stuff has lost some, as we'll see in a minute, lost some signal
of size one, that might be just because it has signals of a different size.
And so we kind of have to look at many granularity measurements together.
But it is a really fun way to sort of see what are the size distributions of things that
you have.
Yeah.
And another thing to note, I think there's also a configurable downscaling that happens
on the image before measuring the granularity.
And so depending on what you have set there, you're not necessarily measuring the erosion
of a single pixel in the original image.
So a further level of abstraction means you want to follow the patterns through the granularities
and not think of it as necessarily always as representing individual pixel increments.
Yes, absolutely correct.
Here I did choose a grid to not subsample.
So my ones are ones and my twos are twos, but you're absolutely right there.
And then because it's always a good thing to do, I made some overlays so we could take
a look at our data because we always want to look at our data and just make sure before
we sort of evaluate the quantitative stuff that our data looks right.
So here I made a color overlay of just the two channels together and then the same thing
with the sort of outlines drawn on top.
So my cells are in yellow, my spots are in white, and here lots of spots and it seems
like it's maybe not getting every spot, but I'm getting overall spotness.
And even if it isn't getting every spot, that's kind of okay because I'm going to be looking
at other metrics too, which might capture it.
And then when I get to the lower levels of drug, much less spottingness going on.
Nice.
But yeah, I think that pipeline's doing a good job.
Yeah.
Lovely little pipeline there.
Thank you.
So how can we actually take a look at that data?
So I put together just a little visualization here in Marimo using their MoLab tool, which
is kind of like Google CoLab, but for Marimo, so it's called MoLab.
And I'm using a tool called PigWalker here, PyG Walker, which allows you to do data frame
explanation and like graphing on the fly, and I think is so neat.
So here I've got the data frame that came out of that.
We can see we have our CellProfiler measurements.
We have our area shape, our granularity.
I loaded just the cell measurements here.
So we have like the children punked account and we have all of our mean punked measurements
per cell.
And we can take a look.
So do you have a measurement you think would be a good one to start with?
I mean, I think just punked account is a lovely, very basic thing to start with.
All right.
Start from the very beginning, a very good place to start.
Let's start with DOS in here on the X-axis and also color, because we like pretty colors
around here.
We certainly do.
And because this is on a log scale, I'm going to actually make sure that I specify that
those are going to be on a log scale, because it looks pretty ugly if I don't do that.
The drug addition was added.
Yes, the drug addition was on a log scale.
So it starts at micromolar and then goes down threefold all the way down to picomolar
every three.
And so everything gets very smushed up if we don't look at this on a log scale.
So I'm going to specify that column and color, which are where I'm putting my DOS, are log
scale.
And we have our punked account.
And I'm going to put that on the Y-axis.
So by default, it's aggregating everything, but let's turn that off.
And we have our punked account.
Look at that.
And we can make it a box plot to make it a little bit easier to see.
And there we go.
There's our on the fly punked account.
Love it.
So if I want to throw some other measurements in there, too, I can.
So I mentioned that texture measurements.
Let me go down and grab one of those.
And so here, you know, if I was worried about my punked calling maybe not being perfect or
not being good, I could just try and see if I can get around it entirely by looking for
other measurements.
And so this is and I only picked one texture scale and I did it in a semi informed way,
but it's possible there are other texture scales that would have been even better.
But if we look at this is that the entropy.
So essentially how bad is how bad a job will we do of predicting the pixel three pixels
away?
Is my understanding anyway?
And we'll do a we have much higher entropy and when we have punked up because the role
relationship, which makes sense if you think about like when I don't have many spots, like
if I know this pixel value, I probably know the pixel value three pixels away because
it's probably pretty similar to me.
But when I'm in one of these cases where there's tons of spots, like if I'm in here,
I don't really know what the pixel value is going to be over here.
And if I'm, you know, over here, I don't know if there's going to be a spot near me or or not.
So the entropy of the texture is actually much higher in this case where we have a lot of spots.
Should we look at the granularity too?
Yes, I actually I love me some granularity, despite the fact it's a struggle to explain
it every single time.
But okay, let's do one.
Two and three.
So one, two.
And I do love this on the fly graphing.
It's pretty great.
That is pretty great.
Oh, I dropped it.
Only I knew how to operate a computer.
All right, so that I've got granularity one, two and three.
And so granularity one goes is highest when we have don't have any spots and everything
goes down just a little bit when we get into our sort of bigger things.
But we get to our granularities two and three.
We can see why we, you know, where some of this intensity went.
It went into spot sizes two and three where now we have a ton of pixels that are about
that spot size and therefore our granularity responses there are super high.
Yeah, which which makes total sense because, you know, again, with a sort of a diffuse
background, right, if you're eroding the small, you know, the smallest shape one erosion
you're able to erode a lot more of the intensity than when there are those bright
shapes that form larger structures because if you erode from those larger, brighter
spots, some of the larger, brighter spots still remains.
Yeah.
So and I bet if we plot these things against each other, so I could even I could take
dose off the x-axis and put like our punct account on the x-axis and which I'll now have
to take out of log scale because now it's not a log scale thing anymore.
Pop that back to linear.
And if we look at our granularity two and granularity three, we look at punct account
versus granularity, you can see there's such a clear relationship there.
Yeah.
The more punct that we have that are which happened to be about that size, then the more
granularity sort of pop there.
Nice.
So we really didn't even need to find the punct unless we wanted to specifically say something
about like each cell has 10 punct and maybe maybe we do.
But I'm able to get sort of the smoothness or roughness of the cells based on some of
these other metrics instead and not worry about having to do my punct of, you know,
segmentation and did I do a good job?
Did I find everything?
Did I miss the ones that were touching the nucleus edge that I really did want?
Yeah.
All of that's still captured in my other measurements too.
And also, you know, really nice to have.
I mean, so nice when you have a visual phenotype, right?
Where you're like, okay, I know that over, you know, across my drug doses here, I absolutely
should be able to find something, you know, something, right?
There must be some metric that's going to capture this.
And so to have that sort of known fact then allows you to, I think, have confidence in
exploring other features, other mathematical ways of capturing this with a level of confidence
that if it is not, I guess, of the inverse, you know, if it is not showing a difference
across this drug dosage, then it is definitely not a metric that is helping you capture
your phenotype in any way.
Yeah.
And like the granularity one there definitely didn't seem like it was doing that much.
Let me put dose back on the X axis and yeah, just pop count out for now.
Like granularity one was only kind of, you know, like there's a change there, but our
box plots are overlapping.
Like you wouldn't say that that was a like big change there.
I would not want to set up a big screen using just that metric.
But for two and three, like heck yeah, screen away.
Yeah.
I mean, you can basically even kind of see where the IC 50 for this drug is.
It's like somewhere between like this dose and this dose.
Yeah, pretty cool.
Yeah.
So that was so if you're trying to sort of get a sense of how punctate your signal is, this
is just some of the ways that you can do it.
Feel free to comment with any others that you can think of.
I love it.
Thanks for sharing that, Beth.
I mean, again, anytime there's an episode involving sparkly cells, I'm here for it.
Always better when things are sparkly.
Always better.
But the fact that we have now a number of episodes talking about puncta within cells,
shows how interesting this question is in so many different biologically relevant models.
Yeah.
That capture might be lysosomes or, you know, Golgi or, you know, nucleolite or whatever.
But yeah, no matter your punta, no matter how your cell is sparkly, you know, we'll help
you figure out exactly how sparkly.
Absolutely.
Thanks, babe.
Thanks.
See you later.
Bye.